The Real Life George Bailey
The Real Life “George Bailey” Who Founded
Bank of Italy, which Would Become Bank of
America
The man was A.P. Giannini who was said to
be who Frank Capra modeled the character of
George Bailey as well as the bank president
in Capra’s 1932 movie, American Madness,
after.
At the age of 14, Giannini left school and
began working with his step father, Lorenzo
Scatena, in the produce industry as a produce
broker.
By the time he was 31, he was able to sell
much of his interest in this company to his
employees and had planned to retire.
However, one year later, he was asked to join
the Columbus Savings & Loan Society, which
was a small bank in North Beach, California.
Once he joined up, he found that almost nobody
at the Savings & Loan, nor other banks, were
willing to give loans to anyone but the rich
or those owning businesses.
At first, Giannini attempted to convince the
other directors at the Savings & Loan to start
lending to working class citizens, to give
them home and auto loans, among other things.
He felt that working class citizens, though
lacking in assets to guarantee the loan against,
were generally honest and would pay back their
loans when they could.
Further, by loaning them money, it would allow
working class citizens to better themselves
in ways they would not have been able to do
without the money lent to them, such as being
able to buy a home or to start a new business.
He was never able to convince the other directors
to begin lending to the working class.
Not to be dissuaded, he then set out to start
his own bank.
With $150,000 raised from various friends
and family, Giannini founded the Bank of Italy
in 1904, which would be a bank specializing
in loaning money to the common man.
The first Bank of Italy branch was in a converted
saloon across the street from the Savings
& Loan he had formerly been a member of.
The assistant teller at the Bank of Italy
was the former bartender of that very saloon.
He then went about educating the working class
on what a bank does and how one could help
them.
Also, because working class individuals typically
worked very long hours, Giannini’s bank
stayed open until around 10pm every night.
At the time, banks traditionally closed around
3pm.
Most importantly, he also made a practice
of not offering loans based on how much money
or equity a person had, but based primarily
on how he judged their character.
Within a year, Bank of Italy had over $700,000
in deposits from these working class individuals,
which is somewhere around $15-$20 million
today.
Two years after the Bank of Italy was founded,
the great San Francisco earthquake of 1906
occurred, which was a 7.7-8.25 earthquake
that resulted in 80% of the city being destroyed,
over 3,000 deaths, and around 200,000-300,000
of the city’s 410,000 population left homeless,
because of the earthquake and subsequent fires.
The Bank of Italy managed to be the only bank
able to open back up directly after the earthquake,
despite the fact that the bank building itself
was unusable.
Directly after the earthquake happened in
the very early hours of the morning, Giannini
went and sifted through the rubble of his
building and gathered $2 million into a garbage
man’s wagon, owned by Giobatta Cepollina
whose son would go on to work for Bank of
America because of a promise made by Giannini
to Cepollina in exchange for use of his wagon.
(Cepollina’s son was able to retire from
Bank of American at 41.)
After gathering the money, Giannini then took
it outside of town, covered in garbage to
protect it.
Next, he headed out to the docks and setup
a temporary bank with two barrels and a piece
of wood as his desk.
He then began taking deposits and giving loans
to help not only businesses, but also the
working class, so that they’d have the money
they needed to rebuild their homes and their
lives.
At that time, none of the other banks had
re-opened and most did not do so for several
weeks, so few who kept their money in banks
had access to it and many others had lost
everything in fires.
Giannini also immediately sent two ships to
Washington and Oregon to acquire large amounts
of lumber to try to work around the inevitable
materials shortage that he foresaw.
That lumber comprised most of the lumber available
in the early stages of rebuilding San Francisco.
Because so many had lost everything, including
identification papers, Giannini gave these
people loans based on nothing but a signature
and a handshake.
He supposedly never tired of mentioning to
other bank big-wigs that wouldn’t loan to
the common man that every single loan he made
that way to so many working class individuals
was ultimately repaid in full.
During his time with Bank of Italy and eventually
Bank of America, as it became, he instituted
a variety of practices that are standard among
nearly all banks today.
He also was a key figure in making California
what it is today, including: being an integral
part of the California wine industry getting
started; providing numerous loans to various
entities in Hollywood in its early days, by
starting the motion-picture loan division,
which provided loans to many budding Hollywood
groups and individuals including funding Walt
Disney’s Snow White, when it had gone $2
million over budget; and funded the United
Artists, which was founded by Charlie Chaplin,
Douglas Fairbanks, and D.W.
Griffith.
He also loaned money to the founders of HP,
William Hewlett and David Packard, to start
their business.
More significantly, he had his bank purchase
the necessary bonds to fund the construction
of the Golden Gate Bridge.
And, of course, the aforementioned integral
role in financing much of the rebuilding of
San Francisco directly after the earthquake
of 1906, among other things.
By 1930, Giannini had retired once again and
this time moved to Europe.
However, his successor began running the bank
like traditional banks of the day, only lending
to the wealthy and well established businesses.
Because of this, Giannini came back to the
United States and rallied various employees
and depositors to him, with them buying shares
in the bank until they owned the controlling
interest.
He eventually accumulated enough shares owned
by working class citizens, who backed him,
to allow him to regain control of the bank,
at which point, he returned it to its former
ways of lending to the “little man”.
He did not retire again.
Much like the fictitious George Bailey, Giannini
kept little for himself through all this.
Despite that fact that the bank he started
was worth billions at the time of his death,
Giannini’s entire estate was valued at only
$500,000 when he died at the age of 79 in
1949.
He avoided acquiring great wealth as he felt
it would cause him to lose touch with the
working class.
For much of his career, he refused pay for
his work and when the board attempted to give
him $1.5 million as a bonus one year, he gave
it all away to the University of California
stating “Money itch is a bad thing.
I never had that trouble.”
Bonus Facts:
• After the earthquake, it was reported
that only 375 people had died as a result
of the quake and the destruction was largely
downplayed by the media, due to the government
feeling that if the true numbers and level
of destruction was reported, the city might
struggle to re-build, with most of its citizens
moving away.
This actually happened to a certain extent,
with many in San Francisco moving to Los Angeles.
This resulted in the end of San Francisco
as the dominate city in California.
• Interestingly, many of the fires after
the earthquake were started by firefighters
and citizens on purpose.
The firefighters were attempting to use dynamite
to demolish buildings to create firebreaks,
but were untrained to do so and generally
just started more fires as a result of their
efforts.
It’s estimated that these fires resulted
in about 50% of the fire damage to the city.
Further, most insurance policies at the time
did not cover earthquake damage, but did cover
fire damage, so many citizens saw to it that
their homes damaged by the earthquake burned
down.
• In 2010, Bank of America was forced to
pay $137.7 million after they were accused
by the federal government of defrauding schools,
hospitals, and various state and local government
organizations by illegal investment practices.
Presumably, Giannini is rolling in his grave
right about now.